what is the situation with availability
of penicillin because the health
secretary Steve Barclay we had him on
sky this morning says people in his
Department are telling them that there
is a decent supply of the drug
um well Jane if there is decent supply
of stock
um pharmacies are not getting them
um every time they go online to order
from their wholesaler and a red line
comes up saying it's out of stock and we
are contacting quite a lot of
wholesalers around the country and
unfortunately that's the message we're
getting now since uh you know November
we've seen a big rise in the number of
prescriptions for antibiotics and so the
demand is there but unfortunately the
supply is patchy so if Mr Barclay has
the supply so we would very much like to
see this flowing through pharmacies
what where do you why do you think there
is this problem is it is it a localized
problem and you're you're talking about
Pharmacy wholesalers I mean we know that
the anecdotally are some shortages in
particular areas
um but but are you saying that this is
across the whole country
this is across the whole
the host of Southeast saying that they
are finding it very difficult to order
um antibiotics and um it's it's you know
having to to call a lot of suppliers but
unfortunately the same message comes
through that there is um you know there
is not in in stock at the moment so um
it's you know we're doing everything we
can to make sure that we get it for our
patients and I don't want people to
panic that there's not going to be
anything available we are really working
hard to ensure that we get the stock the
stock and one of the things that we're
doing is is to Liaison with the
government to make sure that wherever
they say the stock is they make sure
that they they flow through to
pharmacies
because it's not flowing through at the
moment I mean do you think it could just
be a supply problem do you think
essentially there are you know as the
health secretary says that there are
enough they're just sitting in a
warehouse somewhere
we don't know and we've asked the
department on a number of occasions to
bring stakeholders together from
manufacturers to pharmacies and
wholesalers to see where the holdup is
so that we can then find Solutions and
plan better
um so so we know since November that the
number of prescriptions for antibiotics
have gone up so by having plans in place
we can deal with it much better in the
future
um but you know we haven't heard back
from the department and we're right at
the front line having to deal with this
so if you you and your organization not
had any dealings with a health secretary
at all
um we've discussed with the Department
um um people not the health secretary
um himself
um we're very happy to speak with him
about it but um you know we're not
getting anywhere in terms of like
sitting down and talking and getting a
plan in place
why do you think that there is a
shortage I mean it is is it the case
that there as you say that there have
been more prescriptions uh since
November but presumably that would
happen at this time of year anyway would
it not
well compared to previous years there's
a higher demand for antibiotics that
we've noticed
um and well obviously there's been
higher cases of strip a for example this
winter and and antibiotics prescribed
for that and we've also heard that
there's going to be more antibiotics
being prescribed as part of the
guidelines for for prescribers
um so um it's a matter of planning
better but the whole Supply challenges
have been ongoing since the beginning of
this year you may remember the HRT
challenges that we had earlier this year
and so that is why it's essential for
everyone within the the supply chain to
come together facilitated by the
department to identify the issues Jane
so that we can move forward and we don't
find ourselves in this situation over
and over again
why do you think you are having issues
with supplies of different drugs at the
moment this year
um well it could be a number of factors
but unless we have that conversation
with manufacturers suppliers
players and the department all of us
together to identify what the problems
are it's very difficult to say exactly
where the issues lie
um you know some manufacturers for
example tell us that the issues live
with with not having the raw ingredients
which tend to come from the forest
countries because of the lockdowns that
I've had
um is to do with you know having gone
through the pandemic for a long time and
the fuel and and you know Workforce
challenges so you know there are a
number of factors that they are telling
us about this but it comes down to
sitting down and looking at what is the
problem and finding Solutions and plan
better
um I mean if you don't know what the
what the issue is it's hard to know how
quickly it can be resolved but do you
think there is a quick way of getting
these drugs back in circulation
well um we are definitely hoping and as
I said we are really working hard to
make sure that we get hold of these and
and by liaising with the department and
and by making sure that there's no stone
left unturned for our patients but at
the moment people are having to travel
far from one Pharmacy to another
Pharmacy I had reports today for example
that patients have had to go to 12
pharmacies before they actually found
antibiotic somebody has had to go 20 12
20 miles to to get hold of it
um but I want to reassure people that
we're doing everything we can to resolve
this issue but we are
um you know we need the department to
work with us online
how worried are you about the this lack
of Supply it seems at the moment
well I am worried about it my members
are worried about and pharmacies are um
so
um
it
alics are
um commonly prescribed I mean you know
particularly during winter time
um and we don't want to be in a
situation where we don't have nothing
for for our patients and so the demand
is there we've got to have the supply
and we are on the front line it's very
difficult to turn our patients about a
particularly worried parents
um but it's out of our control
okay Leila Hamburg CEO of The
Association of Independent multiple
pharmacies very good to talk to you
thank you very much